you know the saying if you don't use it
you lose it well intermountain
healthcare the sponsors of this next
segment want to ensure our seniors stay
sharp we stopped by to learn more about
their memory exercises and ways to
prevent or slow down cognitive
impairment
hello welcome to intermountain
healthcare this is the sunreach primary
care clinic my name is dr elwen maieri
i'm a primary care physician here i
specialize in internal medicine and
geriatrics
today we're going to be speaking about
cognitive impairment
and specifically cognitive decline
and we're going to be looking at some of
the things that can affect your memory
what to look out for
and we'll try to discuss some things
that you can do to prevent
cognitive impairment or cognitive
decline you can recognize signs of
cognitive decline
by
their very very
various categories for example memory
loss is one of the most common ones and
one of the first things that we see
usually family friends or family members
can recognize patients with
[Music]
loss of words sometimes they have
difficulty communicating not remembering
um names that's probably the most common
thing
there's also a loss of functioning
inability to do simple tasks for example
if they were able to operate a coffee
machine before they might start having
issues with that
a lot of times they also have issues
with
directions you know if before that you
are able to go to a particular location
without assistance
they might start having issues with
getting lost here and there
also issues with calculations simple
calculations so we also notice changes
in personality it could be mood changes
like anxiety increasing depression and
this usually stems from the fact that
the person knows that they're having
these issues and that can affect their
behavior or their relationship to other
family members
now with cognitive decline the main part
is the short-term memory that's the one
that we're concerned about
so
part of our annual assessment we ask
questions like what did you have for
dinner last night
okay
and or just simply do you realize you're
having issues with your memory and if
the answer is yes
then we go ahead and we do something
called a mini cognitive screen debra i'm
going to ask you some questions okay
listen carefully i'm going to give you
three words just three random words
don't think any of it but i want to try
to remember them okay they have to draw
something you know try to remember a
couple words if that screen is positive
then we go ahead and do another
comprehensive test i know you mentioned
some concern about your memory but this
screen was not normal
so what we'd like you to do is
we want to make sure that you try to
prevent probably decline as much as
possible things you can do anything to
stimulate your brain reading
is very important
learn an instrument
learn a new language
play games that are very stimulating for
the brain it's very important that we
not put labels on patients before we
rule out other causes
unfortunately if it turns out that the
patient does have dementia it's
important that we take steps to prevent
further decline and we have to always
plan for the future as this could really
impact the patient's life and also the
life of family members which is what we
do here in the office
thank you intermountain healthcare for
sponsoring this segment for more
information just head to
intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada we'll be right back